[موسيقى]
علاقات بين رياضه واشنطن هي يعني ما هي ما
هي يعني كويسه يعني فيها في في توتر في
العلاقه خاصه مع الحزب الديمقراطي والرئيس
بايدن
معامله معامله الرئيس بعيدا للسعوديه
الكلام اللي قال له
الطريقه اللي بيتكلم فيها عن السعوديه
وحتى سياساته اتجاه السعوديه وهي انه طلب
من السعوديه انه
الانتاج النفطي يزيد عندما يريد ان
يخفض من سعره اما لضرب ومحاربه روسيا او
لتحسين
الوضع الاقتصادي في امريكا لكي يفوز في
الانتخابات في امريكا يعني علاقته
بالسعوديه ما هي علاقه ما هي علاقه نديه
ما هي علاقه بل هي علاقه نوع من الاستعلاء
فيها نوع من
اتجاه اتجاه المملكه فا بالاضافه الى ذلك
ان كان بايدن او قبله ترامب يعني
علاقتهم بالسعوديه تجاه امن الامن القومي
السعودي ما هو يعني ما في ضمانات عندما
ضربت ايران مثلا في سبتمبر 2019 المنشات
النفطيه في السعوديه لم ياتي ترامبو يدافع
لم يفعل يدافع عن السعوديه نفس الشيء يعني
نفس الشيء مع بايدن يعني ما فيها الضمانات
[موسيقى]
العداء الامريكي الروسي ما في ما في
اديولوجيه يعني ما في ما هو خطر مثل خطر
الماركسي او الخطر الشيوعي العداء بين
امريكا وبين الصين كمان ما له علاقه
بالايديولوجيا هو هو
يعني هو صراع على هيمنه اقتصاديه هيمنه في
العالم
فالسعوديه لم تجد تقاطع مصالح ايديولوجيه
مع الولايات المتحده في عدائها للصين او
في عدائها للروس
في المملكه مثل مثل دول اخرى يعني مثل حتى
الهند تحاول ان تبقى على حياد من هذا
الصراع وان تستغل الفرص الموجوده في هذا
الصراع لبناء او
لابقاء علاقات مع الطرفين بس المملكه مثلا
علاقاتها الاقتصاديه اكثرها مع الصين ولكن
علاقتها استراتيجيه والعسكريه مع الغرب
فتحاول ان تبقي الطرفين اصدقاء لها
[موسيقى]